not even three years ago think about
this you guys Barack Obama was President
of the United States but now his legacy
as chief executive is drying up first
Trump came in and began undoing his
policies but now even the Democrats are
turning on the former president in the
last democratic debate round candidates
took turns bashing Joe Biden for his
connection to Obama's policies on
immigration and other issues now new
reports say that Obama personally urged
Biden not to run and is worried that his
gaffe-filled campaign will further
damage Obama's legacy buck Sexton gonna
give us some clarity on this he hosts
the buck Sexton show thank you for
coming out tonight buck I appreciate it
thanks for having me you know it is an
interesting turn of events so we never
would have imagined this but we do know
that Barack Obama effectively destroyed
the Democratic Party with Obamacare in
that 2010 shift they lost a huge number
of their backbench their talent
backbench
and he was really not worried about the
health of the party going forward or any
any even really major messaging do you
think now Joe Biden is still nicely head
in the polls do you think this problem
is going to be the thing that undoes him
and presents somebody else is the
front-runner well I think that Biden has
been the candidate in the lead by
default up to this point and he's been
essentially riding on the fumes of the
Obama of the Obama presidency he doesn't
have Obama's coattails anymore though to
hold on to and when people learn more
about him as a candidate they start to
think who is this guy exactly remember
for eight years he was VP he was
somebody who yeah he was that a lot of
events his name recognition went up
dramatically which is a big difference
from 2008 when he couldn't get more than
four or five percent in any poll his
people didn't know who he was who he was
across the country but then when you saw
eight years of VP people think okay a
continuation of the Obama legacy but
then Hillary swooped in and was the
candidate the last time around so if he
was so great why wasn't he the guy then
he seems to be the guy now because
there's nobody else that has come to the
forefront that the party can really get
behind that I just say some of these new
things that are coming up like maybe
they're not going to give him so many
events late in the day
they're gonna try to come up with a new
way so he doesn't get tired if he wants
to be the leader of the free world we
can't be trying to come up with ways to
make this well you lose your book that's
what of course the primary season is for
you find out what people are made of you
learn about who they are you know you do
have some name recognition with with
Vice President Biden but that's about it
but you do find out and that's what how
people learned about Trump you find out
if someone's consistent who they really
are if they're gonna talk to you about
policy or not if they've got it's not a
joke I mean the president's got high
energy if you've got the energy and the
wherewithal to deal with this but that
is pretty saw that report in the hill
that it was like well in order to stop
the gaffes then maybe they need him to
stop talking at certain points it's it's
only gonna get more intense isn't it I
mean as as more people fallout from the
Democrats and then you might have a
general election it's impossible for
them well it's not just the pressure
that will increase when there are fewer
candidates in the race and clearly
Biden's gonna be around for quite some
time it's also when all of a sudden
Donald Trump who we saw last night in
the usual form that that he shows which
is a guy who's an incredible entertainer
a tremendous amount of energy and also
is a fighter especially on the campaign
trail
they got Joe Biden up against him and
keep in mind you know you've had the
Democrats saying that that Trump doesn't
have the mental faculty to be President
they talk with a 25th amendment well as
a result you're gonna look at Biden's
age his temperament his energy that's
all completely fair game stuff now and
when you see the Democratic Party by the
way repudiating as they do the last
debate Obama's legacy mark I gotta ask
you though I gotta ask you this when we
talk about that people say Barack
Obama's concerned about Joe Biden and he
was concerned about the campaign is that
what Barack Obama is really concerned
about when he tries to stop a Joe Biden
from talking or running no this is a
very this is quite an Obama ism actually
you mentioned the start of the segment
that Obama was incredibly successful
running for himself at different points
in the political campaign the Democratic
Party was in shambles when he was done
and his success at the ballot box never
translated into other people and I think
that's why Joe Biden this time around
this time they're just there hoping that
Biden he gets surpassed but he does not
collapse
stepping in we got to go and I have a
feeling this is going to be you know a
premonition here about what we're gonna
see coming up buck thanks for joining me
I appreciate it